in 2022 the 2022 World Cup kicks off on
Sunday with Team USA playing its first
game Monday but for many soccer fans
this year's tournament comes with a lot
of controversy the host nation Qatar
faces criticism over its treatment of
Migrant workers as well as for its human
rights record including laws
criminalizing homosexuality yet more
than one million people are expected to
attend the competition in person and 5
billion will be tuning in worldwide in
this podcast World corrupt Roger Bennett
delves into the controversy surrounding
the World Cup the men in Blazers host is
also a co-author of the book gods of
soccer the pantheon of the 100 greatest
soccer players Roger good morning how
you doing oh Nate when I'm in the
presence of the one true royalty line
Gail King that's what I'm talking about
I say that every morning we say that
about you Roger now Roger uh World Cups
have been held in countries accused of
human rights violations before
1934 foreign Mussolini's Italy comes to
mind but why is this different this is
like for American audiences this is like
lifting up March Madness and saying
we're going to play it in Saudi Arabia
it's almost The Perfect Storm of
authoritarian grotesness you have
corruption as to why it was awarded
there in the first place in our podcast
at doj spokesman Matthew Miller who was
there when it was awarded to Qatar
called it the most corrupt thing he'd
ever seen in his lifetime and then they
added and I came through in New Jersey
politics yes you have a country that's
not fit for purpose smaller than
Connecticut this is going to be like the
fire Festival of World Cups layering all
the human rights abuse women's rights
lgbtq plus right tribution press freedom
and then you have the fact that the
guardian reported six and a half
thousand foreign workers died making the
country ready for our entertainment this
is truly going to be a World Cup soaked
in blood for a country that's basically
the size of Connecticut I mean Roger you
you you're very graphic you say when
Qatar was awarded it you practically
soiled your pants that's how upset you
were that's how upset you were you have
loved this game since you were a little
boy that you know they said the process
you could literally see money Changing
Hands literally
and so they're awarded this why are
people supporting it then why why aren't
teams saying well we don't want to play
in a place like that in the World Cup
has been compared to a global Eclipse it
hits the entire planet for 30 straight
days instantaneously Andrew you guys
know Nate as well as anybody that Spore
is just an anethetizer we'd look at it
rationally and we understand this Breeze
and Corruption but the second the
whistle blows and all is messy dribbled
through five Defenders slapped home a
kinetic Transcendent rainbow of Wonder
we're like oh my God and that is a
waikato wanted the World Cup in the
first place there's a human rights abuse
there's the deaths of the foreign
workers there's geopolitical conflict
with Saudi Arabia and they want to say
we are here forget that stuff look at
Lionel Messi doing the goal thing right
and it's Sports washing and it's almost
using this Jewel which is the spine in
my life for millions of people around
the world the World Cup gives us the
biography to our life and using it for
brazen a political purposes are we at a
time in our world now Roger where this
organization will stop awarding this
prestigious event to companies like
Qatar good question about this
organization FIFA yeah I mean watch bomb
movies and you know what Specter is it's
like saying will Specter just of its own
accord stop criming I mean the reality
is FIFA is meant to safeguard football
grow it but it does its own checks and
balances and it also knows we don't
watch sports I I watch sports to be
whisked away to get away from the human
darkness and again they know that they
can pretty well do anything because when
Neymar when I'm bafe please God when
Christian pulisic does something
wonderful which is completely mesmerized
so they get away with and they continue
to go away the reform of FIFA ultimately
the only thing that will stop this
because Saudi Arabia is sniffing around
the notion of the 2030 World Cup bit is
this yeah being the most Streisand
effect of World Cups where we both watch
the football and Marvel it but watch it
in split screen and Roger
players make a protest so it doesn't
happen again despite as you say you are
disgusted by it you said we'll we'll be
watching that's that's what I I I went
to Russia in 2018 and I regret it
retrospectively I was doing Putin's bid
for propaganda reporting how great it
was in Moscow in Saint Petersburg I will
not be going to Qatar we're doing a live
tour we're going across America to help
Americans make memories we do just like
politics you don't back off when
politics get stuck we're gonna Marvel
and fight you Marvel and fight we're
going to keep talking during the
commercial break we'll be right back